j'ai écrit des anti-chasse cette affiche
est celle que c'était sûr si sèche dans
ma main à ça c'est le jeu perd dix corps
puisqu'il n'a pas eu la même pas passée
3-0 passé alors qu'elle est pour le bac
la main comment tu fais ce n'est pas
énorme non il a fait ça ça aurait bien
dit polonais non non non on fait ça
comme ça on s'en fout des réponses
tu sais j'ai passé un bac sciences
économiques et sociales ses ou bi est ce
moi est le b à l'époque n'est pas moins
vrai facile que les autres non j'avais
un problème avec les sauve codes et les
kolkhozes tu sais pour l'urss a laissé
faire mes pilotes de l'état des cultures
ne fait pas de mal à circuler sauf cause
des fermes pilotes de l'état etc et donc
j'avais toujours ce doute tu sais pas et
justement j'ai eu du pot le sujet était
à ce propos il rejoint j'avais écrit
sauf qu aux fermes pilotes de l'état
l'urss et gnagnagna voilà et c'est bien
c'est passionnant
et quand vous l'écrivez bien oui c'est
passionnant passé alors on faisait pipi
sur les plonge du professeur et pour
faire diversion et riche et ça c'est
dans la nuit
c'est jean pascal au lion non non non
non et non
c'est une fille c'est une fourche basse
samia ghali mais non on voyait alors je
me suis occupé mag aider pour que je
comprenne comment vous arrivez à faire
pipi c'est aux enfers dont le fils du
quinqua et loch ness donc ce n'est pas
ça mais en fait on délégué un garçon
partout toilettes avant que le profil
arrive il fait pipi sur les penchants
remet tait et on écrive un mot sur le
tableau comme ça on était sûr qu'il
allait faire une chronique wavin moquer
de lui donc il rentre un peu énervé
prenez-le éponge il appuyait bien comme
ça ils essuyaient tac tac tac étonnant
qu'on était de dos nous déjà rentrés
mort de rire et en plus on pouvait
tricher machin que c'était pas mal
d'accidents mais pas amis n'iront pas
forcément mais plusieurs fois c'était
les enfants
de vieux
jeux je draguais ma prof pour avoir des
bonnes notes j'angoisse car pascal
saeyvoet c'est vrai
c'est quoi les draguer toute l'année ma
prof de français et elle faisait croire
qu'elle est parce que je sentais qu'ils
avaient quelque chose à être très jolie
en plus en fait j'ai pris une cartouche
énorme sama j'ai eu mon bac mais j'ai
appris la cartouche
j'aurais voulu d'accord mais ça n'a
jamais je sais que j'ai fait un faux
certificat médical pour louper un examen
bertrand des
citoyens avant que les cucquois comme à
la bave j'ai dit que je n'étais pas bien
du tout et ça se voit dit que j'étais
pas bien un médecin qui écrit
et tout ça pourquoi parce que april 2500
en école de journalisme et en une
semaine seulement on père le prince
rainier à monaco oui c'était un coup dur
j'en paye deux
princesses
étaient bloqués je suis resté bloqué à
une corde aubade de gym
mais non c'était l'épreuve de la corde à
noeuds et je suis restée bloquée sur le
nom j'ai jamais pas
[Rires]
c'est marrant il ya peu et ils m'ont
même quota de passe le bac et où il ya
une corde elle c'est une corde à noeuds
j'aime bien j'ai vomi looking back alors
failli
think that way
en fait c'était pour le pour le bac
français jeu j'avais tellement peur de
ce bac français parce que je capte et
rien que la nuit à force de enfin voilà
trop d'émotions j'ai vomi vomi vomi
jusqu'au matin donc je suis arrivé au
bac français totalement déshydratés et
carrément je divague et donc j'ai fait
ma copie et touche j'étais contente
alors c'est vrai que je suis sortie une
heure et demie avant les autres je me
suis dit tiens voilà et en fait j'ai
oublié de faire toute une partie du
sujet à mince et quand j'ai reçu mes
notes j'ai vu un 2 sur 20 et où je me
suis dit alors je suis allé chez voilà
et j'ai
habité ou bien je pensais vraiment avoir
un doute non juifs et or si j'ai plus ça
va aller encore passionnant
examinateurs pour avoir le batteur
ludivine sagnier gonflé
même voie ludivine franchement vous vous
arrivez assad examen un peu habillée
n'ont qu'à bac des façons soit très
légère parce qu'à moi les sh au mois de
juin bien sûr des 500 légère mais je
suis allé le savent au rattrapage
j'avais que sept points trouvé trois
fois rien et je suis arrivé on a discuté
un père m'a dit mais vous venez pour
combien j 7 points me dit bon c'est bon
réalisme
chez canon mais j'ai cassé mon truc qui
m'a des cas par ce point de plus et j'ai
triché grâce à
d'abord fait un bond
encore une bien belle anecdote et on
avait droit des petits encas et en fait
j'avais climat réponse dans une crêpe
merci merci merci merci
mais bien les stars
je vais repasser pour avoir des points
je vais repasser mon permis de conduire
et au moment de prendre la convocation
il était mon chien était en train de
râler cannes staff est en train de
manger ont décidé la convocation